notre gestion elle est irréprochable de
nature joviale la mairesse de montréal
revenait à peine sa colère aujourd'hui
en se présentant devant les médias
depuis 24 heures son administration a
été écorchée par des reportages sur
l'utilisation des fonds octroyés par
québec pour freiner la violence armée
dans la métropole on est trop fort
personnes attaquées notre intégrité
l'intégrité de notre administration mais
également l'intégrité de l'institution
qu'est la ville de montréal des sources
avaient aussi révélé à radio canada
jeudi soir que bien que l'impression ne
soit pas généraliser certains
fonctionnaire au ministère de la
sécurité publique questionner
l'utilisation de montants destinés au
service de police de la ville de
montréal on va est clair l'argent prévu
pour les hommes
l'argent qui est prévu pour l'habitation
vaut à l'habitation l'argent qui est
prévu qu on les parque bord qu'on les
parquets depuis mercredi dernier un
comité d'experts évalue les besoins de
la police pour demander davantage
d'argent à québec et c'est dans ce
contexte que l'administration plantes
auraient été confrontés à certaines
décisions sur des dépenses d'argent
destinés à la sécurité publique
certains médias ont même avancé que
l'administration plante était soupçonné
d'avoir détourné de l'argent au point
d'avoir fait un des financements
déguisée de la police de montréal là
j'en ai assez qu'on s'a sport au monde
qu'on s'a sport aux policiers aux
policières en disant que notre
administration veut des finances et esso
rarement aura-t-on vu la mairesse de
montréal sortir de ses gonds sur un prix
jugé antipolis qui colle à son parti
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
jamais eu lieu et ça n'aura jamais lieu
sur les ondes du 98,5 fm
la ministre de la sécurité publique
geneviève guilbeault a voulu calmer le
jeu en réitérant sa confiance envers
valérie plantes et nous ont fait
confiance à l'administration on pique si
je dois moi je fais confiance à madame
planches la confiance est là une façon
municipale à montréal afin de mettre
cette situation derrière rapidement le
gouvernement du québec et la ville de
montréal pourrait conjointement faire
une annonce en matière de lutte contre
la violence armée avant le déclenchement
d élections prévues dimanche ici pascal
robidas radio canada montréal